here you go buddy what's up man you got
a question about hypergamy and
something to do with an x and the rules
i reached yeah
long long time watching your good stuff
so my question really doesn't let me
pull like settle down my past
is like i'm 33 i've been in
relationships with my chick uh about
nine years
i was like 22 23 i can figure out
uh we are from russia
both we moved together to netherlands
and like less than a year
living here we split up
and it was like postponed decision long
time and we had like lots of drama
whose decision was it to split up
i was i was guardian on relationships
i'm like very non-dominant very
assertive but still was quite blue
all the way to like a year ago to be
honest
so you left her you threw her out of the
house
or she left you you had like lots of
daddy issues and she was trying to uh
run away every time we were fighting
since like a year first year of
relationships i was always holding i was
one i wanted to make it right and the
longer we were investing together in the
relationships the more i was like
invested into okay we spend so much i
make it right
but over years
i started to give up and i started to
see like ideas from from red view and
from everything else and just like start
the question is it really like it
doesn't really work and my my mom and my
my
parents were telling me like that
doesn't work you're not a good fit from
the beginning actually i was ignoring
what's the what's the conflict because
here in the private chat you say
yes um
her her behavior contradicted the rules
of hypergamy basically if i can phrase
it that way
uh i had uh this this woman uh who was
like clearly deadly issues and like she
always wanted protection and wanted to
be like small girl and i honestly was
like
totally controlling everything i was
like paying for our whole lifestyle all
the time i made good money as a software
engineer so everything was fine but at
the same time she always was fighting
for equality everything she wanted the
voice in every decision she wanted to
question all my decisions always i
always had to fight and reassure every
[ __ ] religion
and then eventually what happened like
when we moved to netherlands and
everything narrowness as you can see
like as you probably know maybe not but
it's very pussified in a society like
northern europe and
sweden and norway is even worse but here
it's quite crucified oh and like
superior blue pill super plugged in
super soft and all like men
up until like 30 or something they can
easily most of the time they leave with
parents or my like they make very little
money
very little aspirations and love so very
quite very let me just take you back to
the point max because i got a lot of
people waiting so i gotta get you know
try to keep this right so
when we split up she found a local guy
yeah
on the side she benefited that he is
local uh she is getting uh her visit
because we were on a temporary residence
permit so he had a support visa support
she split from me she needs uh support
but she found a guy who is like clearly
he's making like three
four times less than me like below
average in netherlands which is like how
do you care
right
well he cares because he's because he's
saying that it violates the rules of
hypergamy because she left him for a guy
that's poor
no no no you're you're yeah but she that
he can give her
um he can give her the visa so right off
the bat that's a way that he's out she's
with me as well like i i was supposed to
have residency with you
did she have a green card did she have
residency with you
yeah it's it's like residency for five
years to get residency where you ring
you every year and after five we can
apply for permanent residency or
our choice but but i mean she get a lot
quick quicker by living and marrying
with this guy though right these guys
she got to be a visa for five years it's
still
before they're on their relationship
where did she meet him did she work with
him like how did she come across him
we split up for a year when i had our
relationship so she started dating them
and she started dating yeah and a year
later she just completely split uh okay
so he makes less money than you but what
does he look like
he's uh i'm i'm like i'm exercising i'm
fine i'm not super model but i'm fine
i'm strong uh i'm like dominant in
everything traditional i want to see a
family i want to chill and everything
uh but he he's weaker than me he's soft
with me his personality he is like but
he is very convenient and agreeable he
makes like
40 000 a year maybe yeah okay so maybe
he's a better box yeah so what i was
going to say though
he has much not though because he makes
less
got it got it so i mean like here's the
thing that you got to understand about
about hypergamy is it's it's a
multifaceted puzzle of a whole bunch of
different pieces right you can generally
speaking boil it down to alpha [ __ ] and
beta bucks and those are the choices
that women generally speaking make but
there's other components that could be
involved in this you guys came from
russia
russia russia's a different country from
the west maybe she came here and said to
herself you know what i don't want to
deal with russia i don't want to deal
with the guy that reminds me of russia
or any of the russian culture i want to
live in the west i want to be free i
want to be a feminist i want to whatever
you know there's any number of things
that could be going on yeah yeah yeah so
there's any number of things that could
be going on her head where you know
she's now saying to herself well mad max
is no longer my hypergamous best option
there's like it's like it's that bad
like the options are that bad where you
live that she chose a broke-ass guy
that's a wimp right
into control because he like approve
everything yes baby
when he's mad he's just silent doesn't
do anything like
here's
here's here's what's going to end up
happening most likely is you're going to
hear from her in the future situations
like that generally don't last that very
long you know she thinks that you know
the grass is greener and that she's
going to do better but she's probably
going to get up get fed up quite quickly
because having a precipitous drop in
household income and financial resources
is not good for women they do not like
that for a long period of time
especially if the dude's not a chat
always always we are fighting for her to
be part of it she wanted to control the
money she wanted to make money and now
here's my here's my closing pro tip for
you is do not deal with this check if
she comes back no no no no no no no no
no just thank god that she's out of your
life
miserable yeah
now a daddy issues chick which i
dodged the bullet in like just six
months like from beginning to end i
experienced all the red flags
just like you said you dodged the bullet
so if you were asking the question
because you're genuinely curious and
thought this might be like a [ __ ] in
the red pill
world and you want to understand it cool
you got your answer but otherwise why do
you care don't care if he's somehow more
red pill in some way that you can't see
more alpha just move on
like don't it's not
like still in in the like in the system
right it's it's just
yeah you just can't see how he's more
alpha there's something about him that
there's more alpha to her there was
something that she was like lacking in
relationships with me and she really
wanted to experience this and she saw an
opportunity with that guy and it sounds
like a control thing that was a better
choice it sounds like a control thing
you know she came to the west she wants
to have more freedom she wants to be
more you know liberal like it sounds
like
she's probably also enjoying being a
special dove getting all this attention
being exotic and you know all that good
stuff whatever who cares uh you know
back to his point like why do you care
like you know who cares just kind of
move on from it like it is
just to see like if there are exceptions
or is like still explains that's rules
yeah that's the meat and potatoes of it
but again you know it's a multifaceted
puzzle with a lot of different moving
pieces and in this situation again it
just sounds like she didn't want to deal
with russia she didn't want to deal with
you she wanted a western life she wanted
a western guy and actually leaving a
tall strong chad that makes three times
more money to go to some dork seemed
like a better choice for her i promise
you it's not going to last very long she
will monkey branch from that guy very
quickly yeah
i bet on this as well to be honest yeah
and some more urging words here man mad
like if you've got what you said going
on with your income dude being from
russia having your head in the right
spot go out and slay it man you'll clean
up out there yeah
yeah yeah that's what i'm doing like um
just
keep getting inspiration from you guys
and uh keep improving on our aspects of
life and
just just enjoy it all right brother
thanks hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you